the women's tennis association has
suspended all its tournaments in china
over the treatment of the chinese player
pung shui she went missing and all
references to her were removed from the
internet in china after she made
allegations of sexual assault on social
media against a top chinese official
pictures of her since have been shown on
chinese state media but the wto wta says
it is still concerned for her safety and
freedom releasing the following
statement this evening pong's message
has been removed from the internet and
discussion of this serious issue has
been sent censored in china chinese
officials have been provided the
opportunity to cease this censorship
verifiably prove that pong is free and
able to speak without interference or
intimidation and investigate the
allegation of sexual assault in a full
fair and transparent manner
unfortunately the leadership in china
has not addressed this very serious
issue in any credible way while we now
know where pong is i have serious doubts
that she is free safe and not subject to
censorship coercion and intimidation
none of this is acceptable nor can it
become acceptable if powerful people can
suppress the voices of women and sweep
allegations of sexual assault under the
rug then the basis on which the wta was
founded equality for women would suffer
an immense setback